the Joe Rogan experience if you say if
you grow if my man talks too much should
I smack him in his face girls would be
like you go girl yes that's true but I
also don't care I'm on the [ __ ] no
but that's because the power dynamic is
the opposite right you know like but
you're talking about the Lord that's a
serious problem of your dating support
yes she's hitting me whatever her hands
are the [ __ ] real issue yeah week we
kept she's gone huh out of the UFC yeah
they [ __ ] up that sucks
they made a video where it made it look
like Dana White yeah they just dr. e
added words that he didn't say that was
stupid so dumb do you think it was
maliciously think it was a legitimate
mistake in terms of translating there's
no way it could be anything other than
stupid what whoever on purpose if it was
done on purpose it was just a stupid
idea that's all it is it's really
whatever it is whoever did it is just
that's a just a terrible error and it's
really bad timing cuz she was almost
uncuttable last year but now Amanda
Nunez came and kind of took that juice
and now it's like she's damaged goods if
she decides to leave the UFC without a
Nunez rematch she beats Nunez she gets
it all back you know but she's got a
one-up seat she'd go to Bellator she'd
go to a lot of places and she'd still be
welcomed with open arms she's she's a
walk down the street and gets a huge pop
star like like she shows up with those
away in shows and like the crowd flocks
there I remember just thinking that
about her I saw her one time and it was
a garden show and just sat in like the
front row of the UFC at the garden and
the place was like look I'm so excited
for just like turning around waving she
was the first like female terminator
gina carano watching her beat up gina
carano gives me nightmares so this is
crazy fight in the end of it when
there's a photo that we played on this
podcast before of her cyborgs hand
palming Gina's had with black
fingernails and she's punching her in
the face at the same time so she's
holding her head just slamming her fist
into facially I want out janitors Gino's
Queen when it was like three minute
rounds there
I'll fought three minute rounds back
then for women yeah yeah it was half
tops you know she was taking some stuff
you know for sure I'm sure yeah yeah
sure
oh this that's part of the issue and
remember is it positive for some stuff
it's you know that's part of what it is
that's part of what it is the build-up
to the Gina Carano fight was when she
choked out the news guy right that was
that wasn't kind of viral was her I got
a news guy being like to put her in like
a rear naked choke mashek choked him
unconscious
he goes back to it's a weird I want to
do it and then he was like you could you
could do it's fine and then he just
looks on it one of those bands on gasser
you get up and make noises believe that
they're really gonna go out like that
they don't believe they're gonna go out
so quick yeah I learned in the sixth
grade we used to do the thing where he
would hyper finally yeah yeah so you
bend over okay and then he's breathe
really heavy for like a minute as hard
as hard as you can and come up really
fast you're already lightheaded then
your friend puts his hands his palms on
your carotid arteries and just presses
kind of light and then within three
seconds you just slide down the wall
whoa it was my first time ever got high
yeah but your friends will let you fall
and hit your [ __ ] head yeah I can
head off a curve you gotta catch'em I
don't think that's necessarily that bad
for you but it's definitely not good for
you it's especially when you're yeah 11
Vil oping developing your own yeah it's
probably shouldn't do it yeah don't be
choking out but it's it happens all the
time in the gym and no one and no one
stops I think it choked unconscious they
wake up and they go back to rollin again
and they the way they talk about it like
it's a garden hose the garden hose shuts
off the power to the brain and
everything's fine but I'm like man you
ain't a doctor show me some long-term
Studies on dudes you've been choked
unconscious mobile talk show me a doctor
making garden hose analogy call me a
[ __ ] I'll tap quick
I'm not going unconscious man yeah stop
that's silly I don't want ya gone
unconscious thing who knows what that's
doing you're going to the Netherlands
you might come back a totally different
person a totally different life
would you open a hundred years you come
back with a false memory of the past
lived a hundred life since then since I
was knocked out that happens to guys
because when they get hit and knocked
out when they come to they do not know
what happened and they have to be
reminded over and over and over again ah
I mean it must feel like you woke up or
ever mentioned like it must feel surreal
well Bisping told me a story after the
dan anderson fight he literally had no
idea what happened it was like he had no
idea where he was
he didn't even thought he thought his
fight was a few weeks out still yeah
that's it was scary [ __ ] he said uh Ben
Askren was saying he has no memory of
like anything in the arena after that so
slow it was one of the worst knockouts
of all time that amount of power that
your flying knee has when you're ducking
into it is accentuated because he's
going in for the takedown and he's got a
strong takedown right so he's going in
with everything he has faced first and
smashing into it running at him oh my
god it's the hole that's the biggest
impact I think I've ever seen as we're
talking about football players crashing
each other that's the moment of impact
we're the dangerous thing about two
football players crashing their bodies
into each other is exactly that yeah and
they super athletes creating that
momentum I mean yes it's nuts how crazy
is it to be undefeated never to lose to
anybody and then that's your one like
your one blemish is like the biggest not
so much [ __ ] that it sucked because I
like Bhau I'm a big fan he's really
funny and then too he talks so much and
when you talk [ __ ] like that and you
[ __ ] lose he's got it he got it eat
those words
so he's marketing himself amazingly and
then that's part of the marketing
himself was like he has his own
down-home version talking [ __ ]
yeah you know even its bloom roasted
things like you could tell it's like
he's almost kind of playing a dufus
character yeah but he's a very smart guy
like I had him on the podcast and he
sends me book recommendations and Chevys
like a really well-read interesting guy
he just that's his character and is in
his part of the strategies to annoy the
[ __ ] out of you but when you flatline
him like that after I know him annoying
the [ __ ] out of you
you know what's that word schadenfraude
house it wasn't word yeah what they're
just desserts
what does that call yeah I don't know
something like it's uh the the pleasure
that you feel from someone else uh huh
obvious demise right is that how they
sounds right yeah is that it pleasure
derived from another person's misfortune
there you go that's what it technically
in a weird way that's what he was trying
to get Mouse with all to do like go
crazy
so takedowns are there yes but if it
doesn't work out it goes very bad
well MOSFET all just took that chance
with that flying knee entry and he
practiced it over and over and over
again and he kind of knew would the way
he circled see the way he circled he
circled off to the side and then came
out on that way well he knew he would go
at him would writing into him that way
and so it perfectly talked because he
was coming out from the side he knew is
gonna lean in that way but he also knows
was all said he was like I was I was
real confident if he took me down I was
gonna get back up and that does kind of
demonstrate that like if you're real
concerned about the takedown you're
probably not gonna open with sprinting
into a flowing name which is funny cuz
Maas vidal's not even a dude who is
known for being this unbelievable
wrestler but first time I saw Maas Badal
was an old-school Kimbo Slice Miami
backyard fighting video though yeah it's
he came out and he fought this guy I
think it was big ray it was I was like
230 pounds and it was George and it was
like a hundred and eighty pounds and he
came out he just boxes dude up and it
was so bad like all the kids were
follows like chickens running around a
backyard it was so hardcore and then he
ends up being so much I think
Strikeforce a few years laters when I
saw him in MMA and he's had a pretty
crazy trajectory to be where he's at
right now he is right on the cusp of
being you know may if he were here when
the title he'd be one of the biggest
stars in the sport he's one of the best
[ __ ] in the sport for sure
there's no doubt about it with
everything he's super well-rounded he
could do everything is takedown defense
is amazing he's got some of the best
hands in the division period I mean you
look at him knock him out dare until
with that leap in left hook the way the
way he did it though he set it up he
landed it earlier and then he landed
again he figured it out he figured out a
spot with his guys open there's like
this dip in what he does
and he found that opening he's
better Riley he's definitely he's
decimal something hated he's more
dedicated you know and now he wants a
big payday and so they're probably
talking about doing that Nate Diaz he'll
get a big pay down at that one that's a
that's a big fight that fight will be
huge
[Applause]